creo que suena muy razonable el que
hagamos otro ejemplo acerca de
ecuaciones diferenciales que sean
separables es en este ejemplo que voy a
tomar la derivada de con respecto a x
igual a una función que me va a ser 10
por el coseno de x ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre 1 + 2 veces de cuadrada
este problema le voy a poner condiciones
iniciales para que nosotros podamos
obtener la constante de integración le
voy a decir que de cero es igual a uno o
dicho otra manera cuando x vale cero que
vale uno este va a ser mi último
problema de ecuaciones diferenciales
separables en el cual consiste en pasar
de un lado todo lo que tenga que ver con
ye y del otro lado todo lo que tenga que
ver con x e integrar muchas de estas
ecuaciones diferenciales que sean
separables vienen de una derivación
implícita o dicho otra manera si
nosotros derivamos implícitamente vamos
a obtener un problema de ecuaciones
diferenciales que sean separables bien
ahora voy a multiplicar todo por uno más
dos ya cuadrada y voy a obtener que 1 +
2 y cuadrada que multiplica a la
derivada de james con respecto a x es
igual ayer por el coseno de x recuerden
que la idea que está detrás de las
ecuaciones diferenciales separables es
pasar todo lo que tiene que ver deje de
un lado de la ecuación y todo lo que
tiene que ver con x del otro lado de la
ecuación y entonces si yo he dividido
todo entre ella pues me va a quedar 1
entre y dolce cuadrada / jr pues esto sí
multiplica la derivada de ella con
respecto a x igual al coseno de x y
ahora voy a pasar el de x del otro lado
de la ecuación del lado derecho para
dejar todo lo que tiene que ver con que
de un lado y todo lo que tiene que ver
con x del otro lado bien me va a quedar
coseno de x de x perfecto y ahora lo que
tengo que hacer es integrar a ambas
partes de mi ecuación entonces saca la
primitiva del lado derecho y la
primitiva también del lado izquierdo a
ver vamos a integrar cuál es la integral
de 1 entre ella pues éste es más y
logaritmo natural de ayer pero hay que
tener cuidado recuerden que no es el
logaritmo natural de ye tal cual es el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
james porque recuerden que el logaritmo
natural está definido solamente en
números que sean positivos entonces no
tendrá sentido hablar de un logaritmo
natural de un número negativo por eso va
a ser el logaritmo natural de ella y
ahorita que recuerdo esto ya lo habíamos
visto lo habíamos visto cuando decíamos
que la derivada del logaritmo natural de
g
es igual a 1 entre y bueno de hecho en
este caso era de x pero pues es lo mismo
pero
y recuerden que el logaritmo natural de
un número que fuera negativo no tendría
sentido no está definido por eso fue que
yo pongo el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de ella y ahora sí que es
integral de 2 pues va a ser que cuadrada
es 2 ya cuadrada entre 2 que es cuadrada
y del otro lado que me queda pues
integral de coseno de x de x y la
integral del concepto de x pues es el
seno de x más una única constante de
integración la cual solamente ponemos de
un lado de la ecuación no vayan a
olvidar la es muy importante entonces
ahora si ya tengo mi función implícita
de la cual salía en mi problema de
cuestiones diferenciales separables y si
yo uso las condiciones iniciales es
decir que quede 0 es igual a 1 entonces
voy a poder obtener la constante voy a
sustituir allí por 1 y hay x por 0 y
logaritmo natural de 1 se acuerdan
cuánto es 0 y 1 al cuadrado es uno y el
seno de 0 pues también de 0 entonces de
este lado solamente me quedase
ahora sí ya sé que se vale ni más ni
menos que el valor de 1 ya tengo hace y
entonces ya tengo por fin mi ecuación
deferr mi solución de la ecuación
diferencial particular ya puedo poner
que se vale 1 y no quiero entrar en
tecnicismos de cómo se vería la gráfica
o como despejamos aquí hay realmente no
está nada fácil despejar de aquí allí
pero lo que existe es que es una
derivación implícita siguió derivar a
esta función y me fuera de regreso
llegaría mi ecuación diferencial si se
dieron cuenta este ejercicio fue un
expreso pero aunque ya acabe el
ejercicio yo quiero echar un poco de
chisme con ustedes quiero contarles
algunas cosas
la ecuación diferencial que se puede
resolver por ecuaciones diferenciales
separables es decir por este método se
ocupa muchísimo de hecho lo voy a ocupar
en vídeos posteriores así que es muy
importante que ustedes
repasen este tipo de ecuaciones
diferenciales a otra cosa que quiero
contarles es que realmente no hay una
solución o una forma de resolver
ecuaciones diferenciales de manera total
o general donde diga hay siempre que
tengáis una ecuación diferencial voy a
obtener un resultado si lo aplico está
en este método
de hecho en muchas ecuaciones
diferenciales que no tienen solución y
la única manera de encontrar una
aproximación a esta solución es
utilizando un método numérico ode más
bien dicho de otra manera utilizando la
computadora para hacer un análisis
numérico espero en algunos vídeos
posteriores poderles enseñar algunos
casos así eso ya será después pero
seguramente ustedes van a ver casos en
los que yo pueda usar mi computadora
para hacer un análisis numérico y de
hecho la mala noticia es que en muchas
cosas de ciencias de ingeniería o en
general en matemáticas tienen que ver
con estas ecuaciones diferenciales que
no tienen solución imagina es una
ecuación diferencial que tenga un orden
5 o 6 y que tengamos una función muy
difícil del otro lado realmente lo que
podemos hacer es tener una aproximación
por métodos numéricos pero antes de ver
cosas locas como métodos numéricos y
computadoras lo que quiero es que
ustedes creen herramientas con todos los
vídeos que voy a ver en esta sección de
ecuaciones diferenciales así que no se
pierdan los vídeos que vamos a crear
hasta la próxima